the song uh get back when you were
recording it Yoko was in the studio
and every time you sang Get Back
John accused you of staring at Yoko and
he took it as an insult those were very
paranoid times you know and let's face
it we we didn't welcome Yoko in the
studio I know because we thought it was
a guy thing I mean even our even the
guy's wives and the girlfriends and
stuff weren't really welcome in the
studio they could you know control room
for a quick visit right but actually sit
in the in the studio with us it was like
uh no excuse me
um we're working did you have the guts
to say that to John no you did not and
you had said it was kind of obvious
though yes but weren't you acting out
passive aggressively you're sitting in
the studio you're just steaming rather
than saying John in a kind of a loving
way this is hell this is not this is
hurting me I can't work this way to have
someone observing everyone was just kind
of sniping we were just fuming right and
soaking and being kind of you know did
John ever say look I'm bringing he
didn't ask permission no he didn't you
know the thing is it was really just the
initial shock of Yoko sitting on one of
the amps right you know excuse me that's
my amp yeah
um she couldn't use this tool but it
would be mind-blowing Paul it was it was
mind-blowing but
um later on we we suddenly sort of
thought you know what John's in love
with this girl if he wants to bring in
the studio we've got to cope with that
and we learned to cope with it and you
know I now feel that he had the right to
do that
um it might have been better if you've
been a little bit more diplomatic and so
this is hey guys you know I'd love it to
be I I really love her and I just want
to be near her all the time right but we
had to figure that out and we did
eventually but it took some time and
there was a few uh looks went on
eventually you even came to say that you
feel Yoko was instrumental in John's
solo career because uh the inspiration
for Imagine and all of that you feel
came from Yoko that he that was his Muse
so to speak I think so I think you know
uh with the Beatles we kind of we came
full circle and so when we broke up it
was the right time for us to break up
you were young guys you needed to go off
on your own and he'd found as you say
Yoko his Muse and she was taking him in
a completely new direction right so the
avant-garde all stuff we'd liked all
stuff we'd admired in other people but
suddenly he had a ride on this bus
foreign